Julie you have 33 producing credits
which of the films or film in particular
are you most proud of hmm well I think
I'm in a way proudest of a series of
films that that I executive produce that
came out of 911 when I was the chair of
the graduate film department at NYU and
it was a very scary moment for me
because I had actually never taught
before and I taught when I was the chair
of the graduate film department of my
you I taught a class in producing and
the first day of the first class I said
you all need to get your database your
address book whatever it is get the
names of everybody in this class and
keep adding the whole time you're here
because you need people to make films
and you never know what you're going to
need or when you're going to need it but
it's very important to have a lot of
people you can contact so that was the
first thing I said and the second thing
I said was there's really only one
question and producer needs to be asking
all the time and that question is why
aren't we shooting and between the first
class and the second class 911 occurred
why we weren't shooting as the Giuliani
shut down film production everywhere in
the five girls so that was a problem and
I was really stymied for the first time
as a producer I don't know how to get
these students to shoot when it's
forbidden so I came back to LA on the
weekend and I thought about my database
and I called Jerry off say that was at
show time then and I said Jerry I asked
my students at nyu to give me one visual
about something that affected them in
911 and I'd like to show you my pictures
and he looked at them and he said how
about a hundred thousand dollars for 10
student films to air next
dear a 911 and I think that was a very
high moment for me Wow okay i didn't i
didn't know the full background of god
and then the film's did air a year they
did anniversary okay do you still keep
in touch with any of those filmmakers i
hear from them all the time will you
read my script do you know where i can
get financing for this and you know and
some of them have kind of gone into
other walks of life and they still stay
in touch and one is teaching in a couple
of them are teaching at other film
schools and one of them actually who was
you know teaching assistant of mine when
I was at NYU was chinese-american and we
just shot a film last year in Guangzhou
and she went over to run production for
us so that was a very nice moment one of
the students was a Chinese who had a
background in medicine and I knew of a
doctor who had been a who was very
familiar with a program in China in
which Khrushchev had said to doctors in
China I want you to put together the
best of eastern and the best of Western
medicine so that in the Soviet Union we
will have the best of the best and this
doctor knew about all of these doctors
who had worked on that project and they
were getting on in years and he wanted
to document it so this student went over
and did the documentary film for him so
the first day of class would happen and
then do you remember when you heard the
news about the two towers oh yes well my
son called and said this terrible thing
is happening you know right in the zone
this was you know NYU was very near to
where the towers or and where they fell
and it was early in the morning and then
we knew and everybody was reacting huh
and you know in unexpected ways because
some people who I thought would be very
kind of tower of strength through it
fell apart and
and the others the reverse I remember I
had one student who who had been in
Yugoslavia and underrung war-torn years
and the first thing he did was grab
pails and go for water so everybody had
a different way of coming at it yeah
I've heard that before that people that
seem maybe slightly off and some sense
actually fared better during a crisis
than those that seem like they would
handle anymore so then after Giuliani
reopened the city or I mean it's been
some time now I don't remember the exact
turn of events how soon were you back in
the class again oh well the classes the
class went on we plod yes and in a very
short time we got an answer from
showtime i was thinking i know the legal
department at showtime I know the legal
department at NYU there is good this is
going to take a long time but in a
matter of a couple of weeks everything
was done everything was sealed and the
students went forward with their you
know coming up with their projects and
then showtimes selected from those that
were submitted and we went forward and
they got the maid and you know it was
very heartening do you recommend film
school for every aspiring filmmaker what
if someone can't afford it or unable to
get a scholarship no not necessarily i
think it's i think it's a way to get
your films made inexpensively and to be
in an environment and with students who
are like-minded in certain ways who have
who shared with you you know your time
in the universe and it can be very
helpful to you because they they have a
perspective on what you're trying to do
as an artist that actually no one else
has because of that so even the even the
professors or even you know filmmakers
who are well established or famous who
come to talk to the students they are
still talking from a slightly different
place or even a tremendously different
place than the peer group so i think
there's a great
that can be gotten from that and you
know in a short fairly short amount of
time and also the different film schools
let's have different ways of
specializing in how they teach film so
one of the strengths of NYU which is
clearly the one I know the best is that
everyone works on everybody else's film
everybody makes films and it means that
the end of that period of time you know
so much about production that I think
when you get out in the real world
nobody can pull the wool over your eyes
as to what's going on in production and
the same device that you gave to those
students in terms of keeping a database
of everyone in the class do you
recommend that to people that are fresh
off the bus to Los Angeles as well oh
absolutely you just never know when you
know somebody will become important I
mean look at the chinese american girl
who happened to have a background in
medicine or in science who then went to
do this documentary in china which was
the kind of extraordinary putting
together of two people who had a common
interest they wouldn't have known about
if i didn't have the database we're just
film producing begin for you have you
start off every project I know you
touched briefly on the financing of
course well I think every project comes
up in a slightly different way so it can
be that someone walks in with the money
which happened a couple of times and the
project or it can be that I have an idea
or it can be that there's a book that
inspires or that there is someone who is
particularly passionate about a project
and comes to me and you know wants to be
involved and we work on it gently so I
think all different let's suppose the
money's there good thing you have the
script you you know who you're going to
have is the director what are the things
that you start doing I'm casting what's
your day like first day sort of on the
job so to speak have you start
organizing
Jerome's with a checklist well assuming
there's distribution and a distribution
date then I work backward from there how
long do we have to do the
post-production okay how long do we have
them for the shoot how long do we have
for pre-production and I like to get as
much pre-production time as absolutely
as much pre-production time as possible
because it's time and money well spent
because it's not a crew standing around
and a cast standing around while you're
trying to figure out what to do so the
more the more that you can you know be
prepared in pre-production the easier
the shoot in general goes and then you
can address yourself to the inevitable
problems that come up during production
so I would say the first thing that I do
once I had those things in hand the
script the money the director I would
hope that I would have distribution and
know the distribution day and then I
would start with three maybe four files
cast crew locations and legal and and
begin to put things together with a list
now the first thing I ever did in film
was scout locations so I have also got
an idea for a film by visiting a
location and saying to myself I have to
shoot here and then I go looking for a
script where I go looking for a book and
then that's how I get it made and I go
back and shoot there one of the places
I've been to in haven't shot is Angkor
Wat in it it's kind of on my mind a lot
so I'm always looking for a book or a
script that would work well to shoot in
Angkor Wat but other places I've been
and said oh I have to come back is Machu
Picchu in Peru and I shot all up and
down the Nile in Egypt so it excites me
to go to great locations and shoot there
what is it about a certain location
aside from
the physical beauty of it do you almost
feel that there's some sense of I don't
know is there some other sense that you
pick up from going to a certain location
what's just well uh I I think it's a way
of getting to know a place and maybe
because I grew up in the Midwest and
kind of you know circumscribed by the
Mississippi and Missouri rivers and
since st. Louis you know going to exotic
places was something I kind of dreamed
about but never really thought it could
happen and so maybe this is kind of an
extension of childhood dreams but the
unintended consequence of shooting in
these places that have locations that
have really thrilled me is it's a way of
getting to know the people the culture
by being part of it however you know
remote I am because I'm not from that
region there is something that I know
which is how to make a film and there's
something I don't know which is how do
they make films in that country or in
that region and for example um I worked
with a Peruvian lucha Yosa and made a
film they're called Max's missing and
what I saw with his crew who were not
terribly experienced for the most part
is that they function like a family
everybody supporting everybody else
nobody's saying that's your job if
something had to be done and there was a
kind of respect they had for Lucho as
the sort of father figure which is I
think maybe common or maybe this is my
conjecture in Latin American countries
and the combination of the respect they
had for Lucho not that he was giving
orders but that they wanted to do well
for him and the way that they worked as
if they were kind of brothers sisters
cousins to provide what needed to be
provided for the film was it was quite
lovely do you think that exists in
American cinema
American sense I think it can I think it
can exist probably more likely with a
director everyone is like desperately
wanting to work with because they
respect his or her work or in more
likely an independent film where
everybody's so excited to just get to
the end of the day of shooting and it's
something that they hope will shoot them
to the top in the industry but even if
not it's something they really really
wanted to do so in that sense this kind
of camaraderie I have seen happen and
independent feature films what is it
about a director that gives them sort of
the personable feel of a father-like
figure because you know we've heard of
great people great artists that there is
sort of a wall that's put up and maybe
it's by necessity you know and I'm sure
it's got to be difficult to always have
people trying to access you all the time
and need something from you but then
there's those that seem to know how to
just make each person that are speaking
to feel special have you sort of seen
some of the traits yes I've seen all of
the above you know I've seen directors
in my films who get the crew very
committed to them I've seen directors
who are very precise in what they do and
it's it's comforting to me as a producer
that the director has sketched all the
shots has laid it out so everybody knows
what they're doing I've seen you know
scared directors so just yeah it's hard
to say what would make this kind of
camaraderie happen or not happen and
when you're when you do see this
location that's just amazing and it just
all sorts of ideas come to you are there
certain things that you said you know
what this is a no-go aside from maybe
obvious sound issues but are there
certain things like do you have a
checklist like okay this is a very
beautiful locale I want to shoot here
but this is not going to work or this
looks right
well expense or whether or yeah there
are a lot of things to take into
consideration as to whether it would be
possible to shoot at the location or not
and whether it's worth it to take the
gamble of whether you can pull it off
whether you'll actually get the
government sign off or whether you'll
actually you know be able to get the
tourists to stand beside her well you
know whatever Oh in one case I remember
there was a location they said well this
is a nature preserve and you're welcome
to shoot here except that we have a
certain kind of a very rare crane that
is nesting and if it you know if there's
no more need for the nest in other words
if the you know if the baby is born and
the crane flies away from the nest you
can shoot there and otherwise no so so
did you have someone on the set
designated as a nest checker how did how
did you know I think it it just worked
out it did yeah it did yeah Julie every
young artist dreams of creating a ripple
and and you know now with the internet
with Twitter and things can just be sort
of instantaneous all over the world at a
push of a button do you remember the
first time that you said I want to
create a ripple in the world I want to
do something that affects people whether
I'm known for it or not but I just want
to be part of something well the first
thing that comes to my mind is not not
exactly what you're asking but is that I
lived in LA and when the smog was very
very bad and I would get up every
morning and listen to the radio station
and they would come on and the announcer
would be what I call selling the weather
and say and in Los Angeles today there
is no smog and I'd be like oh my god was
so I tried to figure out how to address
that in film and I didn't do very well
um doing it in a kind of you know what
head-on way so I finally was able to do
it with humor
and I had it was a you know just kind of
straight exploitation picture about
called it was summer school teachers and
and so they this girl gets up in the
morning and she raises the window and
looks out at the smog and coughs and the
radio announcer comes on and says in Los
Angeles today there is no smog and it
always gotta laugh but I thought maybe
somebody thought about it afterward I
didn't give up I'm very persistent I
think you have to be as a producer and I
decided that I was going to track down
who was allowing the radio stations to
say there's no smog in LA today when
clearly oh I forgot after he says
there's no smog today the girl coughs so
she raises the window sees the smog the
radio announcer comes on and says in Los
Angeles today there is no smog and she
coughs so I tracked down a foot through
the radio station I started by calling
them and saying why are you saying
there's no smog and they said well
because the thing was that called the
Air Quality Management District in those
days has levels below which they say
it's not smog and I said levels for what
and they said well they only measure for
things so it turned out there were some
things that were very carcinogenic that
might be a very high levels but they
would still be within the rights to say
no smog because it didn't appear on the
list of what was being monitored by the
AQMD then I went to the state and and
reached the head of the Air Quality
Management District and took him to
breakfast and said this should not be
allowed to happen and you know it and
then Jerry Brown appointed me to to the
Air Resources Board anyway it's a much
longer story but yes I thought in
kind of my naivete but on the other hand
eventually people did make a difference
so I wasn't the only one who was going
that route and trying to think about it
whereas before that I think there had
been a different attitude about smog
which I discovered when my mother told
me she thought it was crazy just to try
to do anything about smog I of course
thought she was crazy to even suggest
that I shouldn't try to do something
about small and finally I said to her
one day when she made the comment as we
were driving into Los Angeles I get so
excited when I smelled the smog I said
mother why and she said because it means
jobs so my mother had lived through the
depression so she looked at smoke a
completely different way than I did
eventually she came to see things my way
I know there's a lot of people with old
cars that have really fought that
California smog laws because it's so
hard to get an older car smog and to
have it path anyway they stopped
announcing no smog today they stopped
that so at least accomplish that and and
so what would you tell a young person
that wants to create a ripple and
whether it's something creative or two
you know better the air quality well I
think what I see and think about for my
children and what I think about you know
looking back on my time of you know
being young like in my 20s and my 30s is
that I could have done more but I didn't
know that I could so I think it's that I
think you can do more than you think you
can that's what I would would like to
say in these areas of that you're
passionate about the film is boxcar
Bertha and the way it came about is that
my husband had made a film called bloody
mama with Shelly winters and Bobby De
Niro on and he made it for a IP and they
wanted another woman gangster and I love
to do research I just love to do
research so Raja see was looking for a
woman gangster
and I tried finding information about
women gangsters and other than the you
know the most notorious like Bonnie and
Clyde ma Parker I really couldn't find
much and I called a friend of mine who
worked in the DA's office and I said
getting interesting things on women
gangsters why can't I find anything and
um I was just a stunna sure I just
couldn't find more I thought I just go
to the library and got Alyssa and he
said well until very recently there was
a stigma against putting anything in the
news about women or children and crime
because of the way women were thought of
which is you know not so good but in
this case it worked to their advantage I
guess they wouldn't really get in the
news unless the crime was so notorious
that it couldn't be overlooked so I said
thank you very much i went back to the
library and i found a book called the
two story of boxcar Bertha as told to
dr. Ben L Reitman and it was a story
about a woman who was a hobo in the 30s
and she you know had some intellectual
and artistic background some bit but
basically she was just a hobo and went
from one place to the other bite jumping
on a boxcar when she felt like it she
had a lover who was an IWW worker she
actually end up ended up doing social
work in Chicago before somehow she made
her way to San Francisco and when I
tracked her down that's where she was
living as a complete recluse and I
thought that the section of her story
about not being restricted by any of the
kind of things that we had just come out
of like white gloves and hats and so on
was a very interesting story to tell
that it was better I thought to come at
the idea of women's liberation and their
their position and why they were not
treated equally with men to come at it
in this kind of askew way so that's what
I found
very interesting about the project um so
the writer came in bill corrington he
was quite a character southern fellow
philosopher and he started working on
the project and then brought his wife in
to write with him Joyce Currington and
we ended up in story conference in which
bill said you know we should really
change the title of this to big bill
Shelley so that I could base it more on
my grandfather who was an IWW worker
while showing my great maturity and how
I really in charge of everything I was I
burst into tears and left the room so
Roger came out and said what is the
matter and I said he wants to ruin it he
wants to make it the story of big bill
Shelley and set a boxcar Bertha and
Roger said well that's not going to
happen and I said well why not he's the
writer and he said because AIP wants a
woman gangster movie so if you start
with distribution you have certain
pieces you need to fill in so I was much
relieved by that and then Marty Scorsese
came in and this is where I got a real
eye-opening experience probably the most
i have been experience of my life is as
a filmmaker and Marty had some idea
about the project also that had to do
with his relationship with his brother I
believe and once again I thought oh no
this is going to go all wrong my project
my story about this woman who lived
outside the system and then David
Carradine and Barbara Hershey came in
and Roger thought that Barbara Hershey
was all overweight and he told her agent
that she should drop a few pounds before
we started shooting not knowing that she
was pregnant with David's child so
Barbara and David now brought their own
dynamic to the project and I could see
right before my eyes that I had really
lost control I didn't know how much I've
lost control until we got to camden AR
and saw where the picture was to be shot
Marty had been there for a few weeks
before in pre-production and preparing
and we walked into his motel room in
camden arkansas walls was the entire
film sketched every single shot of the
pictures sketched by Marty and there it
was and we ended up with the Marty
Scorsese film by Scarborough so and how
was that character perceived by the
audience oh by the audience well I'm not
sure about the audience but for me Marty
did so much more with my idea than I
ever could have done that I was just
astonished and thrilled and I mean to
this day I'm really in awe of Marty's
abilities as a filmmaker and he is the
total filmmaker and while I'm not a huge
fan of the possessory credit I think in
Marty's case there's no other way you
know he's seen more films than that
anybody so he comes at it from film
history he has memorized so many shots
of so many scenes and now they go
together and then he uses them and he
you know reuses them in can
interconnected ways that you don't even
you're not even aware of it you're
looking at the film and then if it gets
dissected for you bye bye Marty or by
you know film critic who is very aware
of all of this you're just kind of
astonished again and of course as an
editor even though he had an editor he
worked with you know over time Thelma
Schumacher who was just you know kind of
amazing it was still Marty who shot the
picture it was still Marty saying you
know this is what I want to do and so I
always thought that he was the real
force behind the editing of any of its
pictures and it didn't stop there I mean
anything that affected his picture he
was not happy to turn it over to
somebody else the music bhaskar Bertha
what was the musing from the get-go he
was listening to Delta blues and he was
yeah did you ever keep in contact with
the real life Bertha no she was very
reclusive
you never would speak to me we we
tracked her down and we got her to sign
a release and paid some money to her the
public the Bennell reitman was dead the
publisher had gone out of business there
was just tracking this woman down was
extremely difficult and I actually did
it through there's a kind of hobo
conventions they're kind of you know a
little sub rosa and reach somebody there
who said yeah i know where she's for she
isn't so and do you know why she was so
reclusive because it sounds like her
life had been about total freedom and
why I now the way I don't know I was
never able to find out I'm wondering do
you think that a director should edit
their own film or are they too close to
it is it is it too emotional for them to
really some people say that's where you
have the ultimate control isn't that
editing it sir and it's true well I
think I think by the time a director has
directed a film the director is closer
to it than anyone else and also because
the director shot the film the director
you know framed scene by scene the film
that in general if an editor comes in
and tries to do something other than
what was in the mind of the director
it's a little like something that got
created by committee but mostly you know
we have an editor working while the
director is shooting and you know and
there is an editor other than the
director mostly and so that by the time
the film is finished shooting and
shortly thereafter there is a cut of the
film that we can kind of look at and see
you know did the movie get shot did we
hit something some glaring something
glaring that's missing that we maybe
didn't even think about while the script
was being developed or while the you
know while we were in pre-production or
production or sometimes the reverse we
see things that are really not needed
and it's really sad because you went to
all the expense and all the trouble of
shooting things and they just they don't
move the story forward for some reason
so I think it's so
really important for the director to be
in the editing room I think that the the
editor during the shoot edits according
to what the directors notes are in the
script notes so yeah I think in a way
the director is always a kind of an
editor but it seems like the female
directors are still there's a hindrance
there and that whole sort of percentage
of women moving up in their careers has
not followed with directing maybe so
more so with documentaries not
narratives like well I think it's
surprising to me that it's the more
women producers than directors and in
fact the percentage of women directors
even in the directory skill is
appallingly low but I think Kathryn
Bigelow might have helped to to change
that somewhat and I think in television
there's a difference and it just is a
little perplexing to me why why women
roses producers a film more than
directors I would have thought it would
be the other way I don't know well do
you think in some sense and and this is
going to sound strange but it's more of
a pink collar type of a thing producer
you're handling more details that might
be similar to a secretarial task no
where is no you don't think we're just
behind the camera and that's more well I
think the cult of the director has has
risen since the six east and that the
studios were complicit in it were you
know part of it so I mean it went as it
went and you know because prior to the
60s it was really the producers I mean a
lot of films you don't really remember
who the director was I think people
don't really know the director of Gone
with the Wind for example they think of
the producer are you think of a Samuel L
Goldwyn or of you know so anyway thing
things have changed in terms of N and I
don't know I suppose for the better
because it is put more into the hands of
the more the more creative the director
you know decisions but the producers
decisions are created to the producer
can you know be deciding the location
the cast the crew so at the end of the
day the director now gets credit for all
of that when it may well be the producer
who put it all together so I don't know
how do you think things will change or
maybe they want is this always going to
be more of an exclusive boys club do you
think that down the line as just gender
roles have changed I mean men are taking
jobs as stewards on airplanes and out of
necessity age is the economy turning you
know men are staying home with the
children while women well I don't know
how it will be in the future but his
mother as a mother of two daughters I
would say it has not changed fast enough
so anything to fight those gender
stereotypes that you can think of
suppose you're on a set and you're asked
to go get people coffee and I know
you've said that no one really has a
role that's just exclusively theirs and
everybody pitches in but are there ways
to nicely or maybe not so nicely fight
those stereotypes well I think in a way
that you know society kind of gives
women
somehow it creates an aura in which they
don't really know how to propel
themselves and they're not as encouraged
to do it as men are I think men are you
know his voice also a mother of two boys
and the boys are kind of encouraged to
you know to to win than to you know to
take charge into so in ways that girls
are not and some I'm racking my brain to
think of subtler examples for which I
can't but you know we've all kind of
experience look when I got married my
husband started using my credit card so
I called the credit card company and
said I'd like to increase the amount
that I could you know spend every month
because I'm married now and my husband's
using the card and they said oh you're
married oh well you can't have a credit
card in your own name then has to be in
your husband saying now that was just
something that everybody accepted
because that was just how it was I
didn't accept it it was just maybe a
little faster than the rest and I said
well if I don't have a credit card then
I'm not going to pay your bill so please
come after me because I just like to see
what happens and eventually I never paid
the bill and they would people would
call and say you need to pay the bill
and I say no I'd like to go to court
please sue me and then that never
happened and then eventually they called
every six months and then within a few
years the law changed but when you think
about it it was completely wrong and
that's you know that's in my lifetime so
anyway that's gone I do think that women
need to be encouraged nor to put
themselves forward and to toot their own
horns and to you know go after what they
want and not think oh I won't be able to
do it but it's a little daunting to come
into a male-dominated arena and say
you know my turn but that's what has to
be done so I'm gonna tell you my story
about something that I did ok so so
roger was invited to Dallas Texas to get
a drive-in movie award which was a
hubcap and this was in the nineteenth
nineteen maybe around nineteen eighty
anyway sir roger was invited to get this
award and word came through the
secretary of the director of the
festival the drive-in film festival in
dallas that shopping trips had been
planned for mrs. Corman now I think at a
previous time and this is why I say that
it it has to do with how the woman
reacts as much as how society is so that
was a common way of society looking at
mrs. Corman right shopping trips but by
that time I think I'd produced about 10
or 12 films and I had a certain amount
of confidence and instead of being
offended or withdrawing or saying oh
thank you very much and going shopping I
said well that's very kind to them but
would you please send word back from
mrs. Corman that mrs. Corman is more
interested in co-production deals well
Dallas opened up with people who were
interested in co-production deals and I
ended up making two films there the dirt
bike kid and actually getting the
financing in that direction from da for
da which I made in ireland but with film
dallas pictures financing so i think is
it's important to ask for what you want
because otherwise you're not going to
get it I like that is there a certain
way to ask for it well I don't know that
was the way I have none that's what
happened so instead of being mad about
it it was just a very gracious you know
no thank you and then put out what you
did want
didn't say no I said more interested in
co-production deals than shopping trips
right but thank you very much we've been
told before that Hollywood respects male
female creative partnerships and from a
few people that we've talked to they
always say you know some of their tips
are don't make one person and
disciplinarian of the group but what
would you recommend to people on terms
of choosing a creative partnership I'm
not so sure that I think of what Roger
and I do as a partnership I'm not sure I
mean I suppose people from the outside
would look at it and say that it is but
I think Rogers sosua generous and what
he does he's like you know hundreds and
hundreds of films and I kind of one at a
time and and so on and we mostly don't
work on the same projects but in terms
of what we do in business you know we
own the business together there is a
distribution company there you know
there are common things that we need to
decide about an approach having to do
with how much of our money are we going
to spend on a film and you know what
entity will it come from so on or
discussion back and forth about what do
you think about this after or what do
you think about that director or can you
recommend someone who'd work for you or
you know we really need a key grip what
it this kind of thing goes on on a daily
basis I don't think we've ever had a
serious disagreement about anything to
do with whatever we do in business
together even a boxcar Bertha don't we
both agreed it would not changed to be
about big bill Shelly so I don't I don't
really know how to answer you about what
can someone do because it just it works
okay all of that works okay if anything
there is a kind of question of you know
one wishing the other would take more
charge of legal and accounting because
neither of us really wants to do that
so I don't know I just don't remember
having a serious disagreement about
anything to do with business but I also
know that in our marriage whether they
say one of the big test is if you build
a house and we built two houses and I
think what actually happened which maybe
is what happens on the business end of
this is that we each had a couple of
specific things that were very important
to us to have in the house the location
of the dining room and the location of
the bedroom the size of the living room
and we both wanted the opposite thing
and we just trade it and I got the
dining room where I wanted it and he got
the big living room and that was the end
of it and we never really had a
discussion about it again and the same
thing happened with the second house so
I think maybe that kind of thing is
happening on a regular basis with us in
business which is kind of thinking about
what what's important to the other
person then letting it go and making a
stand and having that be heard and if
you were to start over today in 2013
would you release your films via YouTube
because some of the distribution deals
that you know I've read about that that
you got for some of your films I mean it
was just amazing could do them on such a
low budget and then to land but it
really doesn't seem to exist anymore
there was the Wild West and we're hoping
for I mean for us the internet hasn't
moved fast enough to get you know to get
where it's going in terms of how can you
get revenue in order to get the
financing for the films that you want to
make would you consider you to battle of
course what do you see in YouTube that's
so there's some people don't say oh
it'll never it'll never stick around
there'll be so many copyright
infringement all right well I think it's
a I think it's a beginning and I think
then they'll figure it out you know it's
kind of like how the studio's figured
out about eventually their contract said
that that you know originally they would
say you know for thee for the US and
canada the rights for the US and canada
and then eventually it said for the
universe and tire
every medium now known or able to be
known by the mind of man you know for
eternity oh okay thank you uh who know
maybe but yuck that doesn't isn't really
a planet anymore right but i but i think
that youtube and some of these other you
know online approaches are they're gonna
figure it out and we'll be there ready
to make films